et pour en parler on retrouve un régis
souper qui est analyste à géopolitique
elle est avec nous directeur exécutif
d'interclubs conseil spécialiste des
dynamiques sécuritaires politiques et
géopolitiques en afrique subsaharienne
mais aussi françois chauvancy quai
général des brigades expert en
géostratégie
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france je commence avec
vous régis omp d'abord on a assisté donc
à cette conférence de presse ce matin il
y avait quand même deux figures
importantes de la cédéao la communauté
économique des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest macky sall président du sénégal
le président du ghana également qu est
le président en exercice de la cedeao
comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent eux
accepté le plan de retrait est-ce qu'ils
l'acceptent d'ailleurs entièrement son
plan de retrait de la france du mali en
sachant que la menace djihadiste elle
est quand même très présente et reste
quand même c'est une menace globale pour
l'ensemble de la région sahélienne il
faut dire que pour les présidents et des
leaders de la cedeao où ils sont mis
devant le fait accompli le président
sénégalais faut le rappeler actuellement
il est le président et this de l'union
africaine est donc devant la situation
devant si vous voulez ce qu'on peut
appeler mais plus que des bisbilles
diplomatiques entre la france et le mali
événement tous ces présidents tous ces
leaders de la cédéao s'étaient dit rien
dire ou en rangée du côté on va dire
peut-être de la france est aujourd'hui
il se retrouve vraiment remporta fois
avec cette décision mais qui que la
france motive par le fait
qu'effectivement les pianos de cet été
avec la junte militaire qu'elle ne
comprend pas et que n'admet pas
justement le pouvoir la junte militaire
et que surtout ce qui est inéluctable le
sentiment anti gay ce qui aurait un
sentiment anti-français qui montrent de
plus en plus et qui ne lui permet pas
une limite harmonique politiquement et
diplomatiquement de pouvoir maintenir
barkan dans la forme telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui au mali doit ce qui fait qu
effectivement les présidents africains
est essentiellement non que vous l'avez
rappelé le président sénégalais le
président
gagné qui sont qui sont qui sont des
leaders de la cedeao aujourd'hui se
retrouve devant une situation qu'il
faudra gérer et cette gestion je pense
effectivement elle se fait pas à paris
espeyrac plutôt sur le continent
africain et davantage si la vidéo
aujourd'hui finalement ce qui s'est
passé avec ce riz des plats mois de
barkan pour que tous aient bien pour les
commandants militaires c'est je peux
vous dire c'est l'ouverture de mille et
une interrogations qui s'offre françois
chossy quelle analyse vous faites
justement de ce qui a été annoncé ce
matin d'abord leur train c'est officiel
de barkan du territoire malien d'un
repli qui a été aussi annoncé en vers
les pays voisins ouest africains avec
dans le cadre notamment d'une
collaboration sécuritaire avec cette
force européenne que l'on appelle
takouba
il faut bien constater que la situation
politique pour la france n'était pas
gérable sur le territoire malien il n'y
avait pas de soutien du gouvernement
malien de la junte au pouvoir on ne peut
pas rester dans un pays qui ne veut pas
de vous ce n'est plus la françafrique
donc été normal finalement qu'on quitte
le mali maintenant il faut bien évaluer
les conséquences est ce que le
gouvernement au pouvoir aujourd'hui au
mali est capable de lutter contre le
terrorisme
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point aussi est-ce que la france étant
de autour du mali par ses différentes
implantations militaires sera t-elle en
mesure de combattre efficacement le
djihadisme j'ai quelques doutes parce
que a frappé du niger
où si loin c'est difficile maintenant
est ce qu'on aura le droit de frapper
les terroristes au mali c'était des
questions qui n'ont pas été évoquées ce
matin l'application opérationnelle d'une
décision politique et là effectivement
on peut avoir quelques interrogations
régis umpp est justement sur la manière
maintenant dont les autorités de la
transition malienne vont devoir gérer la
problématique sécuritaire sur leur
territoire qu'elles sont allées les
scénarii possibles maintenant le prouver
scénario qui s'offrent à la junte
militaire aujourd'hui et aux autorités
de transition c'est de dire finalement
la gestion la prise en charge et la
prise en compte de l'âge et de la
résolution de ces conflits nous revient
nous revient d'avoir un os que il a
souvent été passé fait qu'effectivement
la sécurité donc si vous voulez dans la
région était déléguée à la france des
délégués aux forces internationales
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya une
occasion une occasion vraiment en or qui
sauf de façon stratégique justement à la
junte militaire de pouvoir elle-même se
régler cette question et je crois
qu'effectivement ça commence déjà par la
profession des sonars méfions nous avons
au pouvoir aujourd'hui en roumanie des
militaires dont on dirait un film en
sont les tout premiers acteurs de la
sécurité de la région et donc
aujourd'hui je pense qu'une fois
l'occasion lui est offerte évidement de
faire face aux périls jihadistes
évidemment ça c'est juste une profession
de foi après coup on était déjà dans les
âmes qui s'était posé à l'époque bien
avant totalement à la prise de pouvoir
l'élection de ibrahim boubacar keïta
coup d'état aussi pour les mêmes raisons
est qu'il est l'un des rues proches
d'ailleurs qu'il faisait au présent et
bkc de dire que non seulement le
commandement militaire qui répondait à
des hommes politiques n'étaient pas
fiables donc aujourd'hui effectivement
il écrivait qu allen n'étant plus là et
on peut dire à la fois que le
commandement à la fois et politiques et
militaires appartient aux autorités de
la transition et justement aujourd'hui
nous sommes en droit et victoires
doivent conserver de voir comment il fut
témoin l'autorité militaire
la junte militaire au jeu au fur à face
donc aux péris djihadistes qui menacent
et parce que
aujourd'hui encore au mali le pays et
eo2 tir occuper encore par des milices
pas des groupes pas des coupables et
théorique donc la situation n'est pas et
n'est absolument pas résolu donc je
pense qu'effectivement là dessus au delà
de lacérations il faudra voir
effectivement que le principe du
déploiement de la france durant deux
autres blocs de bach à neuf et d'autres
pays pour pouvoir analyser les
conséquences à la fois intérieurs et
extérieurs justement sur sur le mali
françois chose en six ans la
professionnalisation des armées
maliennes justement ce une question
récurrente
takouba la force européenne c'était son
rôle c'était aussi le rôle d'une
certaine façon de barkan emmanuel macron
a réfuté en tout cas un échec sur la
mission de l'opération française au mali
depuis depuis qu'elle y est déployée
mais sur ce
la professionnalisation des armées
maliennes il ya un échec là aussi ou pas
oui et non pour tous ceux qui ont servi
en afrique quel était mon cas dans des
armées africaines
reconnaissons quand même que les succès
militaires des armées africaines en
afrique de l'ouest sont assez rares et
que si le mali prétend effectivement
assurer sa propre sécurité comptait
comme jihadistes on peut s'étonner que
depuis neuf ans cette armée malienne n'a
pas été au premier rang des armées
victorieuses donc je pense que les
conséquences de cette armée
professionnelle ou pas
pèsera lourdement sur l'avenir politique
de la junte dans un premier temps dans
un deuxième temps il faut quand même
rappeler qu une armée professionnelle ça
se décrète pas ça se forme il faut des
années est-ce que suffisamment investi
injustement france françois soudan fille
pourra former 16 armée malienne toutes
ces années m oui tout à fait à ma
connaissance oui moi j'ai formé aussi
des africains la question est
on ti envie de se battre est ce qu'ils
ont envie effectivement d'éradiquer le
djihadisme les équipements on leur a
donné qui est un pronom il fait elle a
été le soutien logistique commenté
ont-ils entretenu leur matériel nous
savons tous que il ya beaucoup de
déficiences et aujourd'hui pour revenir
la question sera les professionnels
c'est un vrai professionnel si jamais
elle devait voir votre tempête mans le
jour ce sera pas avant plusieurs années
est ce que l'on peut croire que la junte
pourra rester au pouvoir aussi longtemps
so
jihadistes je pense effectivement la
question n'est pas une déclaration de
foi c'est dans les akans fait
effectivement si pendant neuf ans
le père était restée encore très
fréquent est encore vif donc j'y suis
moi dans les mémoires au mali c'est que
les militaires qui étaient là d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui effectivement qui sont au
pouvoir ne pas pu assurer cette mission
de régulation de sécurité après
effectivement je je je je veux croire
qu'effectivement les mallié et les
autorités qui sont là aujourd'hui au
pouvoir disposent des moyens des
ressources des ressources qui leur
permettra effectivement de vaincre ce
péril après effectivement
là que la france part que bach en
passant
par cannes justement pour permettre
l'application des accords d'alger signés
en 2015 pour rétablir l'ordre
institutionnel au mali l'état de droit
c'est là le rôle de la minustah et le
rôle de le barca c'est justement de
permettre à la minus mad appliquer ces
accords aujourd'hui quelles sont les
perspectives une fois encore l'état de
droit s'est décrite par un état de droit
il doit être totalement intégrée doit
être dans son intégrité aujourd'hui le
mali en tant qu'etat n'existe pas de
façon de façon constitutionnelle c'est
un état qui évoquait des manques et
démembrée par passer par là donc ai fait
moi je pense que l'état doit revenir
partout et il est où les autorités de la
transition malienne vont pouvoir
justement
mettre en oeuvre c'est l'accord d'alger
avec la collaboration de la minus marc
oui c'est ce qu'elle professe nôtre il
faut il faut passer aux actes et est
passé aux accès de la ville antique
hérité de l'état donc remettre
l'administration remets parce qu'il n'ya
pas que du militaire et aussi du sociaux
et du socio-économique il faut aussi
mais qu'ils veulent penser sur
l'économie fort mais les dispensaires
des commissariats des écoles parce
qu'après après effectivement jeu
j'écoute beaucoup les autorités de
transition il ya un discours qui peut
être très intéressant à écouter mais il
faut passer aux actes les accès de
retrouver l'intégrité territoriale de ce
pays est-ce que ça passe par des
négociations avec les groupes
djihadistes parce que ça c'est une
question si importante qui était de
toute façon éludé avec la présence
militaire française puisque paris refuse
de toute façon à négocier avec les
djihadistes l'un des points fis de moi
qui me tue
dans la brouille diplomatique et
géopolitique dont kill kill qui me
concerne aujourd'hui la négociation avec
quelques peut-être secrétaire mais je
peux vous je vous assure il ya déjà des
négociants secrète mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui tous les militaires ils
sont prêts ils sont vraiment engagés
entre kaki et les négociations vont
avoir des pourparlers avec présent tous
les groupes tous les groupes armés
terrorisent qui est juste moi qui
essaiment dans la région parce qu'ils
estiment effectivement que le cobamil
tell me suffire mais se dira pas
lui-même honneur il faudra aller à la
table des négociations et c'est quelque
chose avec mon kiné qui n'est pas
inscrit officiellement de la doctrine
française est quelque part aussi le fait
que le sujet soit mis sur la table née
thérèse pas et ne plaît pas justement à
la partie française quelque part aussi
que ça a précipité si vous voulez donc
la chute de la relation entre l'âge est
l'intérêt et le gouvenement français
françois chose en six ans la stratégie
qui a été aussi annoncé la suite après
le départ de barkan du mali c'est un
repli dans le cadre d'une collaboration
avec la force européenne takouba en
afrique de l'ouest donc il ya le digère
évidemment il ya aussi un pays important
l'afrique centrale c'est le tchad qui a
abrité longtemps le commandement de
barkan c'est encore le cas et puis
d'autres pays du golfe de guinée aussi
qui font face à des défis sécuritaires
telles que la piraterie sur cette
stratégie là à terme ce que ça peut
donner finalement dans un premier temps
une grande difficulté à mener des
opérations je dirais
complète c'est-à-dire qu'il ya à tout
d'un dispositif qui va s'appeler le mali
c'est à dire qu'on ne pourra pas y
intervenir je dirais légalement
maintenant le fait qu'on reste
redéployés dans cette région c'est quand
même un facteur de stabilité et de
sécurité pour les états qui ont bien
accepté qu'on soit là donc je crois que
la lutte contre le terrorisme continue
or c'est vrai qu'on peut toujours dire
qu'on était opposé nous français à la
négociation avec les djihadistes nous
n'oublions pas que ce sont quand même
des assassins des terroristes et qu'à ce
titre la négocier avec des terroristes
sépare toujours défendable maintenant le
gouvernement malien devra assumer ses
responsabilités en cas de négociations
parce que je ne suis pas certain qu'il
puisse rester au pouvoir très longtemps
dès lors que la roja ouvert la porte à
des groupes extrémistes
maintenant pour la france dans la région
nous assurons notre présence
nous ne nous replions pas nous
réorganisons alors c'est important comme
terme et nous allons continuer le combat
contre les groupes terroristes et on va
soutenir les gouvernements locaux et ont
demandé d'autres ados régis on paie sur
l'avenir des relations maintenant entre
le mali et la france
je vois c'est la grande question est ce
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement
l'ambassadeur français et en étant état
est à rappeler tant aujourd'hui en
france et la question savoir jeudi
qu'elle est ce que est ce qu'il ya
encore une relation plausible le récit
on vivait durable quand le mal ici
hormis la france totalement je pense que
c'est une relation va se construire et
aujourd'hui elle se décrète pas et je
suis convaincu que dans les mois et dans
les semaines et les mois à venir la
france reprendra langue avec avec le
mali mais ça m a fait compliqué ça va
être assez difficile je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement français
et la junte militaire francs malik
maliennes sont tous deux s'en sont à des
points totalement totalement divergents
de compréhension même du conflit de la
façon je pense que chaque piège chaque
camp a sonné l'appréhension et moi je
suis convaincu en réalité on parle
beaucoup de sentiments anti français au
mali et d'ailleurs c'est totalement faux
je crois qu'en réalité ce que re ce que
ne souhaite pas les maliens c'est que la
france continuait d'être dans le même
format aujourd'hui et yappa ya pas bhl
il ya pas de sentiment anti-français et
et quelque part ça peut être manipulé
saab est instrumentalisé fait plutôt une
dénonciation de la politique africaine
de france et d'ailleurs qui est plutôt à
l'oeuvre et no et moi je suis convaincu
c'est bah ça ça reviendra ça deviendrait
au moins un autre et la transpose pour
conditions un retour à notre conseil
constitutionnel effectivement pour qu'il
y ait des élections que la junte
militaire cède le pouvoir à un
gouvernement civil mais ça va être ça va
être dans la durée parce qu'en vérité
look la jeune fille et la prend le temps
de s'organiser est aussi exactement le
décile est immense ses jours sont
peut-être comptés si elle ne parvient
pas justement à juguler la menace
terroriste m
et vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer que l
est les recherches d'autres partenariats
or en droit de la france du portugal qui
sont internationaux et empêcher
justement là sentiment de puissance mais
je pense être juste qu'ils se décrète
pas et à un moment j'ai vraiment un
autre la france redevienne drap un
acteur diplomatique important aux mots
au mali mais à condition que les
relations soient apaisées et qu'on soit
dans un respect mutuel merci beaucoup à
vous aurez jcp analyste géopolitique
directeur exécutif d'interclubs conseil
spécialiste des dynamiques sécuritaires
politiques et géopolitiques en afrique
subsaharienne merci à vous également
françois chauffant si pour votre analyse
vous êtes un général de brigade expert
en géostratégie